- I am so far from being a prostitute
and so far from being even an escort.
I am sex artist, and I did  not pick that job.
The job picked me.
- [Mark] All right, Francesca.
- Oui.
- [Mark] Frenchie or Francesca?
- Both
- [Mark] Both.
And you grew up where?
- France.
- [Mark] Paris?
- Paris, outside little town but Parisian,
because it's cool but really suburbian, yeah.
To be honest (laughs).
- [Mark] And how, tell me about your childhood.
You had both mom and dad?
- Childhood, damn!
Short version or long version (laughs)?
- [Mark] Both.
- So short version.
So try to resume.
I was born in America.
My dad was a super cool musician compositor
making quite amazing soundtracks.
And he is kind of the one that had the master idea
of making us, us as my twin and I, born in America.
So when my mom got pregnant, he woke her up
in the middle of the night and told my mom,
we gonna make the kids in California
so they can be American so they can sponsor us when they 18.
So from the start, my dad used the kids as,
I mean, the key to America.
He was obsessed with America back in the 80s
where it was actually easy to come and immigrate.
So my mom arrives,
I think she was two or three months pregnant, yeah.
And then my dad did his the music,
and we were born with my twin.
- [Mark] And how would you describe your childhood?
- So, very good with my mom, okay?
My mom is an amazing woman, complete unicorn.
100% Hungarian, first generation of Hungarian in France.
So she's this woman with drive and ambition
and she's like the role model.
So my mom made sure that our childhood
was gonna be stable.
My dad, however, ever every chance he got,
he was destroying all my mom's work
with little things that he would do.
He was very much of a marginal.
He did not put a lot of rules.
You know, he bought us, scooters very early
and let us go with my twin until really late at night
where we could really get in a lot of trouble.
Lots of problems could have happened.
And my dad was very oblivious about denture.
My mom was super like careful with us almost,
yeah, almost not letting us breath.
and letting us grow up.
And when we'd go to my daddy,
it was the complete opposite, you know?
So it was those two extremes.
They fought a lot, absolutely.
Like, I mean, my dad was in and out of my life.
Tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock, I called him the clock,
because he was this weird tick-tock,
back and forth and back and forth.
And I think he did some what created
some type of daddy issues, especially he was a--
- [Mark] What word did you use?
- Daddy, daddy issues, you know, having a dad,
not only in and out of your life,
very loose when it comes to education and reinforcements.
And also always asking me why I'm not like my twin.
Why aren't you like her?
And the problem with being a twin
is when you are a single child,
you are taken as is.
But when you have a twin, suddenly you are always compared.
In my point of comparison, was this very mellow twin,
you know, very, very mellow.
And I wasn't, I was the super hyper child, you know.
And my parents thought I was, something was wrong with me.
Nothing was wrong with me.
It's only wrong if you compare me to a very mellow child,
then something is wrong with me
because I am not a mellow child.
So it was actually difficult to be in her shadow
all the time.
And now, I knew my twin like myself.
She was the half of me.
And I was always wondering why the fuck
they wanted me to always be like her
when she was nothing very interesting
to be honest with you.
She had no talent.
She was not creative.
I don't know, at six, seven years old,
I was studying writing poetry
and my IQ was actually, you know, superior.
So it was very strange to be compared to something,
somebody so mellow and so most insignificant.
- [Mark] Were you a bad girl?
- I was not a bad girl, I was hyper, so--
- [Mark] So like in high school,
were you getting in trouble?
- No, not particularly.
No, no, I had a lot of energy.
So my mom decided to convention gymnastic
and all that energy I became a champion.
So 13, 14, I was doing nationals.
I was on my way to the Olympics until I fractured my ankle.
But I was, yeah, I pretty much transformed my energy
into something that was going to be talents, you know.
And so this is what I did with my life.
My whole childhood was to be a gymnast.
So no boys, no flirting.
My twin sister has 5 inch on me, 12 centimeters,
a whole little head on top of me.
So she was the model and she was the beautiful twin.
And I was the talented gymnasts,
and I kept my spot like that, and I was happy.
I was happy to be the gymnasts,
and to be the entertaining kid in high school.
So was my childhood chaotic?
My parents' relationship was.
The way I grew up, my mom made sure that it was stable,
my dad destroyed a lot of that.
But overall, quite normal.
Yeah, quite normal compared to most kids.
- [Mark] And after you got out of school,
you had jobs or no?
- Ooh la la!
No, because in France, it's completely different
than in America.
So, oh, it's a whole story.
At 16, 17, I was, my mom is a teacher,
and she's very scholar.
My twin sister was the super child in school
and she was very scholar.
I wasn't, I was good half and half.
If I was interested, super great,
if I was not interested, super bad.
I mean, mathematics and XY to equals zero,
question mark, parenthesis, you lose me there.
But you give me language and history,
and I was good at that.
So I mean, no, I did not have a job, definitely not.
But what I started doing at 17,
I'm just trying to like piece it.
So my job pretty much at 16, 17 in the private school
because my mom wanted me to be scholar,
and wanted me to graduate.
Instead to do that I was surrounded by rich kids.
And I put real quickly A and B together.
The supply and the demands.
And the demand was they want the weed,
but the supply was zero.
So I decided to go to Amsterdam
with my boyfriend at the time.
And it was this bus called Odyssey.
And it was a package, bus, breakfast, Paris, Amsterdam.
So I had the idea, let's go to Amsterdam, pick up some weed
and then we're going to sell it to the private school,
to the rich kids (giggles).
So I started doing that.
And I started to actually,
I mean, my business was the only one,
I had monopole, the absolute monopoly
on at least 60 miles around.
So people would literally travel to buy my weed.
And I had five different type of weed.
I would go to coffee shop in Amsterdam,
I would take a bus, and I would make sure the bus
would cross the border of Netherlands, Belgium,
Belgium, France at night.
So the chance of having the custom stopping the bus
was pretty much zero, it never happened.
And it just became,
so I went 32 time between the time I was 17
to the time I was 19.
My mom found a couple of kilos of weed,
because it was only weed,
I never felt with anything else, but marijuana,
just because I guess I believe in it.
It's just this amazing thing that make you feel good.
And I just get caught by my mom and she sent me to America.
This is how I was sent to Santa Cruz, where I was born,
and very bad idea because, sorry?
- [Mark] How old were you?
19, 2002, yes.
So I was sent to Santa Cruz where I was born.
And Santa Cruz, I don't know if you know,
but everybody grows in Santa Cruz.
So I believe he was literally the first guy, Kevin,
that I met at the smoke shop to buy rolling papers
to roll joints.
And I met him, and he started asking me questions,
where are you from, and everything.
Do you wanna manicure the weed,
clip the weed for me?
Sure, and so this was my actual first job in America,
it was to clip weed (laughs).
So my mom is trying to save me from weed
and she's sending me to the weed town.
Yeah, recipe for disaster (laughs).
Yeah, so I cheated on him, on my ex-husband with him
the day before my wedding (laughs).
I did, I did, he would slap me,
but I needed to know and put something aside,
I didn't have the bachelorette,
like all the girls before I got married at 19.
And I was like, that's it, that's it, just one for life.
And I had such a big crush on this gorgeous guy
that gave me my first job.
So, yeah, I cheated on my ex husband,
soon to be a husband, the night before my wedding.
- [Mark] Wow!
- Judge me motherfuckers!
(Mark laughs)
Sorry, I did it.
I was young, I was 19.
I didn't know better.
And I'm glad I did.
I'm glad I did (laughs) now that I know what I know.
- [Mark] And so you got married.
You have children?
- Oh no!
- [Mark] No kids?
- No, no, thanks god,
No kids, no.
But at one point in my life, yes.
Yes, it's just I had some abortion with the same guy,
with him over the nine years.
And I think at, it was 17, the first time, 17,
I was more ready at 17 than I was at 24,
the last time I got pregnant from him.
Yeah, it was bad.
So super toxic with him.
Oh, yeah.
But I think at one point, I would say, because of him,
today is thanks to him.
I don't know what I want in life,
but I know what I don't want.
And anything close to what I had with him, I don't want, no.
So I'm a late bloomer, I started my life as me without him
or for him or around him or being a thing at 26.
So my life started at 26 years old.
I'm pretty much 12 years old
when it comes to experiences and ascension.
I was in a plateau, big plateau, for nine years.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] Interesting.
- Yeah, one extreme to the other, 100%.
I was a little housewife and it was good at it, you know?
Yeah, and it's my space.
Actually, thanks to my space that is shattered everything.
I'm one of the first social media victim.
He left the page open.
And he was talking to a, oh, fuck, it's another story,
he was talking to a gang girl from the Nortenos, okay?
And I was so confused.
Here is my best fucking friend that I know for nine years,
Bonnie and Clyde, my everything--
- [Mark] This is your?
- My husband.
- [Mark] Your husband.
- And I remember when I realized he was cheating on me
using my space and cheating on me with a bad,
not good looking Mexican girl in a gang,
and was thinking, this is how the fuck you going
to leave the American dream with me?
This is a fucking nightmare.
It became a nightmare.
Trust me, he regrets that choice for sure,
like this girl must have made his life hell.
He had a kid with her and the gang after him.
And it was the family, I mean, he must have suck (laughs).
But karma, karma, is a bitch, you know.
Karma is a bitch, for sure.
So that's my story how I divorced.
I mean, my space made us divorce,
and yeah, the social media,
they will wreck your your marriage if it's not strong.
So I guess he wasn't strong, he wasn't.
If something as weak as my space broke us,
yeah, it wasn't strong, obviously.
It was just an illusion.
- [Mark] You had other jobs after that?
- Yeah.
That was my ascension in the corporate world.
So the Wharf, those are shops.
So then the name was Outdoor World (laughs).
They fired me when I was on my knee, folding the jeans
and putting it on the shelf, like a good girl that I was.
And they called me over the microphone.
And then I went to the office, you know.
And then you little, you like 20 years old,
and you don't know why you're getting called,
and maybe it's for a good thing, you know.
It's not for a good thing.
No, they're just firing you like this.
Like, you're awesome, but you need to go.
Not really any explanation,
I guess it was before the three months.
And then, they don't wanna pay the benefits.
And I quickly understood the corporate world,
little cheeky thingy.
Oh, quickly, yeah.
So you cope because you don't have nothing else.
The corporate world is really all that you know
and all that you are introduced to.
So after that, I worked at the cosmetics.
Yeah, I was selling the makeup.
And it's a crazy story too.
I was so envious when I would go to Neiman Marcus
and Bloomingdale's and Nordstrom.
I would see all the girls like absolutely so cute
at all the counters all dolled up.
And I saw a job offer for Chanel.
So ello, I'm French.
I went to the interview,
and it's one of those group interview.
Like those group interview is enough
to give you a heart attack, I swear,
because it's like all those girls,
the managers, everything.
And if you don't have confidence, you're going to fail.
But I like groups, and I like, I don't know,
like let's show off, you know, why not,
I'm French, it's Chanel, let's do it.
So I remember he was like this whole table
and they ask you the question,
you know, your name and all that shit.
And everybody's kissing ass.
But they asked the question,
why did you wanna work in makeup?
So I must have been like the fourth or fifth one,
so my head is going, what are you gonna say,
what are you gonna say?
So my turn, and I say,
you know, I met this woman in Los Angeles,
and she told me that woman's best friend was diamonds.
And I told her, the woman's best friend is makeup
because without makeup, you don't get the diamond.
And this is how I got the job at Chanel,
not knowing fucking shit.
So they gave me the secondary interview.
So now I'm like alone with like all the manager
from Neiman Marcus.
And I made up this biggest story ever
that I was on the Champs-Elysees,
you know, and working for Chanel.
And I know they're never going to actually call them
and make sure that I work for the Champs-Elysees on,
it's literally like it's the biggest store
on the most famous street in Paris.
I don't even know how the fuck I got away with it,
but I got away with it, yeah.
And next thing, you know, boom,
I'm becoming the best seller of the counter.
I'm like the top seller there.
I was doing really really good,
until it was like this weird recession, right,
2008 or something.
And then like this little dude,
you know those stupid morning meeting
where they're like brainwash the fuck out of you.
And I remember that morning meeting at 8:00 am.
You don't wanna wake up, but you have to wake up
for that damn morning meeting
where they want to push the super amazing
Neiman Marcus credit cards, you know?
And I had such a hard time hustling those poor clients.
Well, rich clients, I even see even the rich people
have a hard time fucking hustling.
I'm not a hustler.
But I had a hard time pushing that credit card shit.
I'm French, okay.
We live with what we have, no credit card.
And we don't try to make people sign
for stuff they don't need, you know?
So it was complicated for me.
So that morning meeting, this guy,
the regional manager or somebody higher up,
somebody that you kiss ass, his ass and stuff.
And he's telling us that we have to actually
kill our commission by 30% and give pretty much 20% back
to Neiman Marcus (laughs).
Yeah, so I went to the middle
and I'm like, well, yeah, but why not?
But why not?
What is next?
And everybody, and I see everybody, literally the faces,
okay, we see it.
No, it's not okay.
You are really making us wake up in the morning
when I wanted to sleep because my shift was 1:00 pm.
But when it's your shift at 1:00 p.m.,
no, no, no, you have to still wake up at 8:00 a.m.
and hear this bullshit from this little dude
that you don't even know, and tells you that,
oh, from now on, you're going to give back
your commission to Neiman Marcus.
No, no, no, bro!
So I walked out.
Then I worked at a bank.
I'm not going to, you know, let's not just say the name,
but it was cool (laughs),
I loved it, actually.
It was not as much money,
but it was something about that bank.
I don't know.
It was my little bank.
I would call everybody by their name.
I just liked the dynamic.
It was an easy dynamic.
I was a little teller with my little badge
and I would like take care of the volt and the ATM,
and they will give me more stability.
And I guess in a way was comfortable,
we got robbed and stuff.
Yes, oh, that's another story,
but it was not me getting robbed.
I was in the volt.
Yes, I had to buy some money from the volt
to put it back in my drawer.
And while I'm doing this, we are getting robbed.
In and out.
The guy he's like giving a note,
I have a gun, give me the money.
And the girl had to do it.
Her name was Ether.
Ether, you literally handle it like a champion.
So the news interviewed her and everything.
It was something else.
Yes, so we got robbed, that bank (laughs).
It was awesome, honestly.
- [Mark] So the bank.
- Yes, the bank (laughs), the bank, changed my life.
It's so funny because the sixth degree of separation.
I would have not worked at that bank,
I would have not be talking to you right now.
So it's funny.
As I progressed in the bank,
I started training the people
that were new on the computer,
F1, F2, do that.
It was so easy.
I had that girl, and she did change the whole course
of my existence, 100%.
So I was in a very small town
where everybody knows each other.
It's such a good town.
And she would tell me, you know,
after work we would go smoke joints together.
And I had the hash, like good hash,
that my boyfriend would send me from France.
And she had the good weed,
so we would like trade and stuff.
It was cool.
I liked her, but I was going through my separation,
I was going through my divorce with this motherfucker,
and this girl, I had one love,
I had like a few guys in my life, few, few, four, four.
And here's this girl.
She's telling me on Monday, she fucks him,
and on Tuesday, she fucks him.
And this Russian guy, and this guy.
In one week she fucks like literally
like more than what I fucked in my entire existence.
So I never judged her.
I was fascinated.
But how easy it was for her not to only talk about it,
but live it completely, fully.
She was like a happy slut.
A fulfilled slut that worked at a bank,
and then every once in a while,
she was fucking Mr. A, Mr. B, Mr C, Mr. Z.
I mean, it was like almost like that.
And I could not relate because you can only relate
with what you know, and you know what you know?
So I didn't know that.
And one day, she would tell me, Frenchie,
you have a broom in your ass, you're so stuck up.
And you have so much potential,
but you just don't know where to start.
And she told me, I'm gonna meet you to a party.
And it was in San Francisco.
It was called the Pleasure Zone, the Pleasures Zone Party.
And those party definitely changed
the whole course of my life again.
So she brought me there and she told me
it was gonna be a sexy party where you wear lingerie.
Yeah, the thing is my ex-husband
was not the type of guy
that even let you wear lingerie for him.
Like he was no, no, no!
It was like out of question to even wear lingerie in public.
But she talked me into it.
She was pretty good at it.
So we went, we went.
And I was in lycra, it was no lace,
no girder, no big hair.
It was like, as basic as you can make someone.
I had those stripper shoes that she gives me
that were way too big for me.
I had a lycra thong and a lycra bra.
And I don't walk like this,
I don't even know, wow, the fuck she did it,
but she did it.
And I remember when I walked in that club,
that party, that 60 party,
I Knew instantly something was just not normal (laughs).
I just knew something was not something I ever seen before.
First of all, I was terrified of the girls being catty
because girls are always catty.
But no, no, no, no, nope.
This party is not catty at all.
All the girls, they literally froze on you,
come, bite butt, take selfies,
come to my table, come to my table.
And all the dudes, they're in the background.
They are the most behaved men that you ever seen.
Nobody's hitting on you but the woman.
So I'm thinking in my little head,
is this like a lesbian raging party or something,
like there's a lesbian with guys in the background
just watching the show?
And, come meet my husband.
Oh, hi, you can come meet my husband.
So I'm telling the girl that I'm with
like I need to smoke a cigarette.
I am outside, and I'm thinking,
what the fuck I'm doing here?
What is going on?
So I'm smoking my cigarette like this,
and I'm stuck, I'm stuck with her.
She brought me to this party.
It's her car.
I am stuck for the rest of the night.
What is going on?
So I am not comfortable.
Everybody's biting my ass.
Everybody wants to take selfie.
Everybody wants to introduce me to their husband,
husband, husband, my boyfriend, my husband.
I don't have a boyfriend or husband.
I come with my girlfriend, okay?
So we are being looked at like, I don't even know,
like meats, like pepperoni pizza or something,
ready to be eaten.
And I don't like it.
So now I'm outside, and woman number two
changed the whole course of my life.
She is the one that really opens the door
to every window right there.
Fucking A, this bombshell come towards me.
And she was so pretty much my age now back then.
So she was 12 years older than me,
she was 38 years old pushing 40, unbelievably hot.
You know, ponytail, her little dimple,
like her big lips.
I remember she just was it.
And she came to me and her energy,
something about her vibe was just,
I don't know how to explain,
like I wanna be you, like tell me how to be you.
It was just like mesmerizing.
And she's asking me a cigarette.
So sometime, smoking can definitely join people (laughs).
That cigarette changed the whole thing.
I'm thinking if I would not have not be there
at this very moment, I will not be there right now.
It would be completely different.
Maybe I would still be at the bank or the corporate world.
I'd be like broke or I don't know.
But she asked me a cigarette.
And then she asking me who I am with.
Are you with a boyfriend or husband?
I'm like, again, I'm like, no,
I came with my girlfriend.
And she's like, oh, are you one of those unicorns?
So I guess, I did not know that the unicorns
back in the day, what they called the unicorns
is kind of like those girls
that come to the swinger parties as single woman
and fuck couples.
So what I answered to, I guess,
I had no fucking idea how crazy that night
was gonna get just because of that.
So she's like, come meet my husband.
But this time, let's go meet your husband.
I'm sure your husband is hot.
There is no way your husband saw a Coachella.
Like she was a doll, absolutely, whoa!
And so we go to the table, and yes husband is next level.
And they telling me they have kids,
they knew each other for 14 years.
And I'm going through separation.
And it's almost like this perfect couple, the power couple.
You look at them, they wanna make you throw up
because they are so fucking cute.
You know, those couples, like you just envy them, that.
So of course I paid attention to them.
I was completely charmed.
And I was charmed that they were charmed by me.
Of course, I'm like, are you kidding me?
You have all those beautiful woman.
You want me at your table.
So I went with it.
And tequila makes you do bad things to good people
or good thing to bad people.
I mean, I don't even know if, tequila is a poison.
But next thing you know, this party's been a meet and greet.
You are not doing nothing crazy, too crazy on that party.
It's pretty much to mingle.
So at 2:00 a.m., it's all there.
And I cannot reach the girl at my right,
the girl that I'm training at the bank
that brought me there.
Yeah, she's gone, okay?
I have no idea where the fuck she is.
She's not answering, straight to voicemail.
I'm stuck.
So I'm stuck with Barbie and Ken, so, cool.
And they telling me, do you wanna come with us?
And they lived over the bridge in Sausalito,
which I never been to.
And you know, usually, you know, your mom
she tells you, stranger danger?
I just, tequila, there is no more danger with the strangers.
With tequilla, you just follow literally anyone
that looks cool.
So I went, I went, and it was good.
And I lost my son, for sure, that night.
I was with Barbie and Ken, gorgeousness.
And I don't know, just something about those two.
I don't know, why those two are, I don't know,
sent from heaven or something,
but I did stuff that night with them
that I cannot really describe or pronounce at that time.
I don't even know how to pronounce what I'm doing with them
but it's cool because I'm having three orgasms.
You know, and oh, man, it lasted all night.
It was ridiculous.
Oh man, we did a lot of things, definitely.
And they are ready to call me a taxi back
because finally, long story short,
I'm finally connecting with my girlfriend
that left me like a piece of shit behind
to go fuck this couple
which ended up being great.
Don't get me wrong because that
that changed my life, for sure.
But now I'm meeting with her but before the taxi arrived,
they gave me an envelope, okay?
And I think is, obviously, because you're not waiting
for an envelope, you're not sure
what this envelope is about.
So I thought they were cool enough to print the picture,
remember we had that back in the day,
it was 12 years ago.
Imagine we had the little cards to put in the computer
and to print the pictures.
And I'm thinking we had picture at the table,
kissing my booty, kissing hickeys, kissing just (mumbles).
And I just thought, they were cool enough
to actually print those pictures.
So I didn't open the envelope, I put in my purse, okay.
I'm exhausted from the night we just had.
So I did not realize it was a lot of money
in that envelope, obviously, until I woke up, okay.
So when I woke up, I wanted to see the pictures.
And it's not pictures.
It's a lot of money.
And I'm a banker, so I'm going like 20, 40, 60, 81,
20, 40, 60, 82.
And I'm looking at the bills and I'm confused.
I'm super confused.
Mega confused.
Mortified with the fuck, you know.
So I called them and asked what the fuck,
and also we get pretty intoxicated with alcohol.
So I just wanted to make sure
they did not give me money
instead of the pictures, dumb ass.
And I'm kind of honest, actually,
I should have just taken it as is.
But no, no, I wanna make sure that he did not get confused.
So I ask him, you know, what the fuck is this money about?
You know, the pictures.
And he's confused with the pictures
and I'm confused with the money.
And then, "Frenchie, weren't you working?"
I'm like bro, no.
I'm a banker, what makes you think I was working?
He's like that you were the only single girl
in swinger club, so we thought you were working.
It was just, it was impossible.
And I'm like, no, no, no, no.
Not even close.
What is a swinger club?
This is my question, to them.
I do not even know what was a swinger club, okay.
That's how naive I was about everything.
Absolutely naive.
More than naive.
When I look back I'm like thinking to myself,
are you kidding me?
What a fucking dumb ass (laughs).
So obviously I hang up the phone and I asked myself,
shit, can you do that again?
I mean, we're talking about three orgasm, good orgasms.
I mean, good shit that we did that night.
Yeah, like almost like opening the pandora box.
- [Mark] And getting paid for it.
- Big time.
Like I remember when I was counting the money,
I was so in disbelief like I'm gonna cry
because it was so absurd that in one night
I made enough to like go back to the surface of my debt
because my ex husband put me in deep financial sheets.
Deep financial, he took everything I had.
So I had to go back to the surface
and boo, like from heaven.
I told you earlier how the universe
manifest in very mysterious ways.
And I have goosebumps because the chance of this
happening to me was zero, zero, zero, no chance.
I am educated by a philosopher mom.
She is so articulate, so smart.
So like delicate that it was impossible for even her
to even, as a mom, think one day I could take this road.
And so it was difficult for her, but she understood.
Today, my mom is absolutely proud of me, 100%.
She understood everything.
She even knows that I am twinkle bell.
I am twinkle bell.
I come to your life to sprinkle absolute magic.
If I need to be a bitch, I will be a bitch though.
I will readjust you and put you back in your place
faster than my own shadow.
That is my goal as well.
I will never make a man,
make him believe that he's a good man
when he's a piece of shit.
That is not helping that person.
And it's not even helping the world.
But I am twinkle bell, 100%.
I'm a bitch when I need to,
and I sprinkle fucking magic.
And not only my mom was smart enough to recognize it,
she embraces it, 100%, you know.
I am so far from being a prostitute
and so far from being even an escort.
I am a sex artist.
And I did not pick that job,
the job picked me.
Again, it was sent from this crazy angel,
like either he fucking crack, or he's like so clever.
It was just the perfect scenario for me,
blindly and effortlessly.
Once I had a pinky toe in that little Pandora box,
I was instantly good at it.
Not only that, go back to the story
when I hang up the phone and ask myself,
can you do this again?
100%, but I only decided to do
every last Saturday of each month.
I don't know, maybe because I needed some normal
and some squareness and some maybe structure
into the deviancy.
Do you say deviancy?
- [Mark] Mmh!
- Being deviant, you know.
I need to have some type of structure
because I don't like when it's chaotic.
So every last Saturday of each month, I became Frenchie.
They gave me the name, not me.
You know, Frenchie, Frenchie.
You know, everybody, it was those amazing parties.
They don't have them anymore
but the pleasures on parties, they were amazing.
Everybody's eye is going to look at this right now,
and they went there,
oh yeah, those parties were the shit, 100%.
And they new me, yeah, very quickly.
So for eight months, every last Saturday of each month,
I became Frenchie, and I kept working at the bank.
And it's not even me who made the choice.
So you have life and options.
And you have option A, you work at the bank and you make,
like 160 hours and you make three grand,
30 to 35 on a good month with commission.
And then you make that per night.
And when you reach $10,000 per month with couples
calling you more than every last Saturday of each month,
at this point, it was from left to right.
I was getting hit up from left to right
because referral, call her, call her, call her.
I did not advertise.
It was natural organic.
It was thrown my way.
So it's almost like I'm like life is aiming at you,
and then either like, it's like a dodgeball,
or you make a lemon drop with sugar rim, you know, and yeah.
So I took the opportunity, yeah.
So it was obvious that when you make three grand right here
but 10 right here, you're not going to keep going there
and exhaust yourself.
I was exhausted.
I hate the of the of the alarm clock.
It would make me pinch in my spiny.
Like, I remember, like after seven years
of this like screaming, alarm clock,
wake up for this motherfucker,
wake up for this, be a slave, be a slave.
No fucking way no more.
It was so refreshing suddenly to snooze it.
And you have not only the right to
but you just could, that's it.
So I told my branch manager, she was the shit by the way,
she was the shit, this woman.
I have to say she was a hustler
in her whole little away.
She was a branch manager.
She knew how to go on golf course.
She would give me advice.
You know, golf courses.
You have to reach smart men business card.
She became a branch manager,
just because normally she was hard
but she just knew how to hustle in the right fields.
And she would give me those little advice.
She was cool.
And so I told her I needed to talk with her.
And we went to the conference room,
and I told her everything.
And she had like such an actress profile
like this blown gorgeous 50 year old woman.
Like honestly, she had a lot going on,
and a little Mercedes, she had a love shrug, for sure.
And I remember her face, her eyes,
when I would tell her what I was doing.
And she's like, Frenchie, good for you.
If I would be your age, I would do it all over again.
She told me that, yep.
So I went, yep, I went full-time,
and then I was like, oh my god, sorry.
I was starting writing a book because I love writing.
So it was called "The Extraordinary Stories
of an Ordinary Girl"
and how suddenly my ascension into this, not only housewife,
but corporate prisoner, one single night, few hours,
not even a lot, like a few hours was enough
to change the whole course of the fucking direction.
So I was writing about that.
And I had little chapters with titles.
And then, you know, with couples,
it's cool, it's awesome.
But you can get some what's repetitive.
And I'm like I need more, I need more, I need more.
Like I need more for the book.
And so sent from heaven again,
the universe manifested again without really trying.
I was flipping through channels on demand,
and I see a house, I click.
And it's the BunnyRanch, it's like the HBO show
about the BunnyRanch, and I am so fascinated.
Like oh, Jesus Christ, like I remember,
I'm like, you kidding me.
I've been in America for all those years,
and there is a place in the middle of nowhere, mind you,
where you can make five to 10 grand per hour?
I'm going.
So, oh my god, I emailed, madam Suzanne.
And I told her that, oh my god, that was just, you know,
kind of a couple of sugar baby, a unicorn.
I didn't even know how to call myself back then.
And maybe I was going to be a good addition to the team.
So she goes back at me.
I need three pictures.
I send the picture.
Five fucking minutes later, my phone rings,
she's telling me like, we want you,
can you be here on Wednesday?
We got your plane on the house.
And I'm like, yeah, perfect.
I'm going to have much to write in the book, you know?
And oh, holy shit, man,
I don't even know what I was signing up for.
But yeah, I did it
Like what the fuck (laughs).
Yeah, when I look back, I was bold.
I had more balls back then that now, you kidding me.
So I went, I went, and I would always remember,
when I were at the airport,
because she asked me, what's your name,
what's your stage name?
I'm like, I don't know.
Well, you know, a stage name?
Everybody has a stage name.
Oh, Frenchie.
She's like Frenchie what?
Frenchie Rose.
So it was Frenchie Rose.
What a dumb name though (laughs)?
They worked, I was Frenchie Rose,
and when I were at the airport,
you had sign, Miss Frenchie Rose.
Pretty much like you are at the Reno airport.
And everybody knows that there is a guy with a nice suit
that wants Ms. Frenchie Rose
which is definitely a weird name.
And so I'm approaching this big old guy with suit
with my suitcase and he takes my suitcase,
and he brings me a limo, extended limo,
with like BunnyRanch on the little plate,
American style, of course.
And I opened the door, well, he opened the door, really?
And then they be six girl, like beautiful girls in the limo.
Like, oh my god, you know, welcoming me like properly,
girl style, like screaming, cool.
And shit man, I was the last one
they were gonna pick up at the airport.
I guess they kind of consolidate
whoever arrive at the airport and put it in the limo.
So we're about seven girls.
Oh man, From Reno to the BunnyRanch.
I had a briefing of 35 minutes of like,
you charge this for this.
And like this guy, if he does that,
we do these, we do these.
This room is this much and...
I remember when one told me that you can ask
up to 10 grand at the VIP room,
I remember back when I wrap myself around the idea,
wait, what, you know, like, wait,
10 grand, one hour in this room.
Oh yeah, every time, oh my god.
You're gonna have like a lot of money, you see.
You from Paris.
I'm like, my head is spinning, 35 minutes
from six girls telling you like that's how we,
it's a dream.
And I'm waiting for the catch because in France,
if it's too good to be true, that means it is.
But no, I have to say, I have to say the BunnyRanch
was next level.
Definitely.
Fuck, where do we even start?
The limo like arrives.
We are parking.
And I remember the arrow, the arrow clinging,
click, click, click, girls, girls, girls, and arrow,
pretty much girls here, girls here.
American style.
You know, I'm from fucking Paris,
and I see these, girls, girls, girls.
And then I remember like, it look cheap.
I don't know how to explain,
like, it's not glamorous.
It's not like sophisticated.
It's not like girls here, and this arrow
clinging American style.
Like, fuck!
And I don't know,
I like that feeling like, what are you doing here (laughs)?
And I arrived, and they were holding my suitcase.
And I arrived in, it's weird because from the outside,
it kind of looks like strange,
it looks like a trailer almost, you know, like--
- [Mark] In the middle of nowhere.
- The inside.
- Pretty much, it's quite isolated.
Yeah, and it's by law.
There has to be away from agglomeration.
- [Mark] Yeah, I photographed there before.
It has to be outside of the county that Reno is in.
- 100%.
- [Mark] It's way out in the middle of the desert.
- The amount of peoples,
so you have a certain amount of people.
It has to be away from those types of city pretty much.
- [Mark] Right, it's just a trailer
in the middle of nowhere.
- That's why it's trailer, so they used to move it
but I think, so let's go back to Dennis house
because I do wanna talk about Dennis house.
But it did change a lot of things.
- [Mark] He ran the BunnyRanch.
- Even Carson City, 100%.
He was a King.
He was the, the, that's it, the, the E,
the daddy D, you know.
So I went to the BunnyRanch,
and I remember always, it was glamorous inside,
like velvet and the little fireplace
and the parlor is really well done, the bar.
And motherfucker, it was this group of girls.
And the energy of those girls almost like borderline
like ghetto, you know, like it came at me
as like I couldn't even understand the slang
'cause I'm French, you know, I cannot understand everything.
And I remember just like the words,
I couldn't understand what they were saying.
And at the bar, it was this little girl I met, Melody,
you know, posh, you know, like, I don't know,
green eyes and like, like super light, and alone.
And so I kind of gravitated towards her,
and I'm Frenchie, and hi Melody.
And so she likes, "you want a tour?"
Yeah.
And so she's showing me everything
and I kind of like lean on her a little bit
because I couldn't relate with the other ones in a way,
but without like being close-minded or anything,
but I go with energies and it just feel like I fit
in that group of girls,
I felt like if I would even approach her,
there was like hyenas.
They were to like jump, you know.
Like I could feel it in the energy,
and I'm sensitive to things.
And I could feel like aggressivity,
like the look, the way she looks, the body language.
Like what the fuck she, or what the fuck,
what the fuck is she?
And so long story short though, like they do test you.
100% of those beaches will test you to the max, and shit.
And then there'd be stories that circulates.
They would put bleach in your shampoo,
and they would sabotage, big time.
- [Mark] Those girls?
- The girls would sabotage, kind of the like top dogs,
top cat, 100%.
And what was funny with those bitches
was if you were successful, you were the dirty hustler.
And I didn't even know what it meant.
So imagine being called a dirty hustler
when you don't even know what the fuck it means.
What a dirty hustler really means at the BunnyRanch,
it means you make more money than me.
And you are dirty hustling.
No, you're just cuter, and you just have more game
and the guy wants you versus her, but you are dirty hustler.
And you had to actually deal with that.
You had to deal with the girls throwing at you names
like you're the dirty hustler of the week.
It was intense.
Like, oh my god!
But yeah, those girls, as soon as you arrived,
you the new one, you fresh meat,
and they would put you to the test.
Imagine me not knowing much of the codes of the lingo
of even like hearing the first time, like a trick,
why you call them chick?
Like, what is the trick, you know?
Cause they tricky.
What'd that mean?
Like, even if you go into depth,
like I could not understand why you use all those names,
the lingo or that shit.
Like I was so French there, you know, super fucking French.
And those girls were like, one, one in particular,
came to me and she said, you are not gonna last a week here.
And in my head, I'm like, wanna bet, wanna bet.
Don't underestimate little Frenchie.
I have way more street smart that you think I have.
And life is balanced,
street smart, book smart.
And you balance between the two.
Too much street smart too, you're a gangster.
Too much book smart you're a nerd.
Be a gangster nerd.
I'm a gangster nerd, motherfucker.
And I showed those bitches respect, 100%.
It was not easy.
It wasn't easy.
It took me a good month.
It took me a month.
I cried and stuff in my room.
It was so bad.
But let's go back to the first day though.
The first day, so you have to pass the STD tests.
You have to pass also the background.
Like you have to be super good girl.
No any type of arrest,
no any type of felonies, nothing.
You have to be a super good girl.
And completely clean from STDs.
So once you pass that,
which is like pretty much a day after,
you had that little message,
like Frenchy get ready for the floor.
So reality hits you like, like a bom, Jesus fucking Christ,
like get ready.
But get ready for what?
Like (breaths out heavily).
So I put my little cool stuff.
And mind you, 12 years ago, I was quite fresh.
Like it was kind of effortless for me
to like put something cute.
And I was like, I so self-conscious
that I didn't even believe in me.
So every single lineup, the first day.
Every single lineup, yeah, I was transparent.
I see this like co-boy, this old dirty dude.
Like I'm like, no, no, no, no, no.
So the first day though, 15 minutes before my shift,
15 minutes before my shift, there is the bell.
So the bell means that you have to line up.
So you run, you run.
And you always have your shoes close to the parlor
so you can jump in your shoes
and like be like the first one,
and kind of like if the guy is here
and you are from here to here, is good.
If you are over there, is not good.
He is not gonna pick you.
Shit scare this motherfucker, okay?
He has 23 bitches looking at him.
Pick me, pick me, pick me, pick me.
And this guy suddenly feels that small, 100%.
But I manage that time
to be in that right place, right time.
And he locks eyes with me, he is cute.
15 minutes before my shift.
Mind you, I had no work that day, nothing.
I'm even asking myself, can you even do this?
Can you even, what are you doing here?
But him, he's adorable, I don't know.
Just something about him, his energy.
And we lock eyes.
I already knew.
Picked me.
And he does, he did.
He picked me.
And fuck, I remember like I shaked.
What next?
Okay, what'd you supposed to do?
So you go on the tour, and at the BunnyRanch,
you supposed to like show this room and this room.
This room is damaged,
this room is damaged.
Oh, look, we have a medical room
where we get our vagina check by doctor on a weekly basis.
So we clean.
So we have to do these like, oh,
almost like Neiman Marcus, same, same,
but different, you know,
like a brainwash of like sell your shit, sell your shit.
And so with him, since I didn't know
how to really sell my shit,
I just kind of went with whatever came out of me.
And he totally lead it, like he led the way.
We went to the VIP room.
So the VIP room at the BunnyRanch, it's awesome.
So you had this big bed, beautiful, awesome, jacuzzi,
like a swing, like a sex swing, Kama Sutra.
I mean, you can hop into all those fun toys, the sybian.
And it's so easy to sell.
Honestly, they make it easy for you.
You have mirrors and everything.
And it's like, not even negotiating with me.
He's putting three grand on the bed
Not saying anything, pause.
At the BunnyRanch, you get monitored, okay?
Your negotiation, back and forth with the client
is listened to by the madam
or whoever is on shift that night.
So I don't know that, I have no (laughs).
I have no idea about that.
I'm using my shoe like Cinderella, fine me.
So the madam is listening to the whole negotiation.
And here I am with this guy
who's was not saying nothing, putting three grand.
So like a dumb ass because like I was very well-trained
that day, you don't fucking fuck up the house
because the house will fuck you a better.
Oh, 3,000, okay.
So I mean, in my head 1500 is nice
because you pay half to the house.
1500 for you, 1500 to the house.
And I remember he roll his eyes,
like is she dumb or what?
Yes, I was indeed dumb.
He helped me make more money.
He puts three grand on the bed, trying to help me
put 1000 in my pocket and only declare 2,000 to the house.
Yes, but you don't understand my love,
you're my first client,
and I don't understand the game,
and I am too honest and I believe in karma type of girl.
So I reach in the 3,000 to the books and I made 1500 bucks.
And I remember always, he is my first client.
So you go to the window, it's like a bank.
You have your little account
and you have to put a little initials.
Yeah, that's 3,000, you making 1500 in one hour.
And they give you these amazing towels
with little glass and the condoms in the loop on top.
Shit, I remember it was so cheap.
I don't know how to explain to you like that moment
of like stacking the cover, the sheets,
like the towels, the claws, the condoms, and the lube,
like a little pyramid.
And then here, take, for you in the VIP room,
super glamorous VIP room
with free champagne on that house.
Champagne or sparkling wine.
Be careful, it's not the same, but yes.
So here I am, and I was on my way
with this dump pyramids of cheapness.
So I remember, from the window to the VIP room,
you have a little corner like that.
And I had that in my hands and I start shaking.
And I looked at him and I went on against the wall
like this, (pants) like, I don't know, like panicking.
And he's like, are you okay?
I'm like, I'm not okay.
I'm like, you're my client ever.
Like, yeah?
I'm like, yeah.
Like I never had a single man like that.
Like you are my first one here.
I just arrived.
He's like, oh my god.
He's like, so he's hugging me,
like, you can see it's really reinsuring me,
like, oh, score, fuck yeah!
And he's like, I'll be the best client you ever had.
Cool, so, I don't know.
Isn't it just cool, I told you at the parlor,
I already knew with his little dimples
and he's like, just like his body language
and the way he locked eyes with me,
it was just almost like already flirting.
So when we arrived at the VIP room,
it has a jacuzzi that you need to fill up
because you cannot have sex in the jacuzzi
not without changing the water.
So it's cool, the way they do it,
because it's a jacuzzi that you can fill up
and then just sanitize afterwards.
And I am studying the jacuzzi,
and he says the ultimate sentence,
"Do you smoke weed?"
And I remember like, almost like, you know,
like the little clouds in the sky.
And that alone made me feel so good.
Like, yeah.
He's like, what I want you to do
is to smoke this pipe of weed
while I lick your pussy in this jacuzzi.
So the jacuzzi is filling up,
so now we like ready to go.
And he's asking me to lick my pussy
while I'm smoking a pipe of really good indica.
And I'm getting $1,500 for this (laughs).
Are you kidding me?
Again, like sent from the universe,
I don't know what the fuck, but it was cool.
It was cool.
It really went well.
So he pay me for an hour.
And after 20 minutes, he's telling me that like,
"I'm so sorry Frenchie, I need to go."
Because he came so fast.
Like, I mean, like I had to do
like barely anything with him literally,
he wanted to lick my more than anything.
And then I just touched his dick a little bit.
And then he came.
So I'm like, well, are you kidding me?
Like, you are in a beautiful setting
with King size bed and jacuzzi and all those things.
And this guy just paid you a top dollar
for absolutely nothing.
And so I remember he's ready to go.
He's ready to go.
And I told him, oh my god, I feel so used.
And he said, "No, you don't understand.
I would say longer but my girlfriend is in the car."
Huh?
Why is she in the car?
Because she didn't have her ID, and the ID her at the door.
She didn't have an ID.
So I had to go, I'm like, oh my god,
she's the cutest fucking girlfriend in the world.
Like, are you serious?
So I eventually met her, when she had her ID back
because that very first clients came back
again and again, and again, and again, and again.
I remember he would bring me to Tahoe
in the presidential suite where you had a comment
and you just push like fire, wind, these,
like I never seen a fucking room
where you just touch a button and it moves, you know?
And here I am with him and his girlfriend,
and I don't know, like full moon
and we were outside together.
And it was like this weird romance of this beautiful
successful entrepreneur, gorgeous girlfriend,
and way too young for her own good to even be with him.
And then even just changing my life,
spoiling the fuck out of me.
This is my first client of first day at the ranch, okay?
And we have on a weekly basis rankings of the top cat.
The first week, I was a top cat, the first week, okay?
The second week, they called me to the office again,
"Frenchie, you need to come.
"We need to talk with you."
Remember when I got fired, and we need to talk with you,
I thought he was to fire me.
And I remember being so nervous,
like, oh, fuck, oh, fuck.
Almost like right back to the corporate world
of like what I knew, like the corporate world.
Like if you get called, you get fired.
You don't get really rewarded.
If you get called to the office, really, you get fired.
You great, but.
No, they calling me, oh my god,
like you remember your first clients,
he just made a deposit,
he wants you for two days.
So from thinking, you're getting fired,
you are making 40 grand.
And this whole switch, oh, my goodness,
it's like almost like a bomb of confidence.
And the more confident you are, the more successful,
the more successful, the more confident.
And you are in a vicious circle of absolute success
effortlessly without even knowing you had it in you,
it's there, bam!
This motherfucker wants you again.
And he just left a $20,000 deposit.
That means that he's gonna spend at least 40 grand on you.
So let me tell you the reason.
It's really cool.
So he brings me in the extended limo
because when you spend a lot of money with the BunnyRanch,
they will provide at least the limo
and the champagne (laughs).
And he brought me as long as you are on the Nevada side,
it's legal.
If you are on the California side, it is not legal,
but who give a shit when you spend 40 grand
and you just tell that you are gonna stay there.
No, we went on the California side.
Mind you, I had no idea what I was doing was wrong
or right or whatever.
I was following this beautiful man
that was putting so much money on my account that I,
it's only in the movie.
It's only the movie, and I'm from this little town
and like all these things.
♪ Pretty woman. ♪
And I went with it, pretty woman.
I went with it.
I told him, you are making me live a pretty woman's story.
So we are in Tahoe on the California side
and there is a casino.
And he tells me wear the skimpiest outfit you have.
And I had this little dress that you really wear as a top.
And blackjack is cool because it can be very much
of an intuitive games.
Okay, so here I am, he is giving me all this cash,
and I'm playing good.
And the guy, the little dealer, his name was Freddy.
Okay, so I am fucking around with Freddy,
like, oh my god, double down or the shit.
And there is this angel right next to me, beautiful girl.
And so my super client is there,
I am there, super angel.
And she's giving me a compliment.
I'm giving her a compliment.
We are starting like making out with this gorgeous girl.
My client that just pay me top dollar
to go to Tahoe with him
is now witnessing me flirting with this gorgeous thing.
And I asked her the ultimate question,
do you wanna go with us?
Fuck, yeah.
Honestly, she saw we were a couple.
So we went back to our beautiful room,
jacuzzi and all that shit.
Amazing, amazing menage a trois.
Okay, so and this guy pay me top dollar,
I'm scoring him a free menage a trois
with a girl that looks like an angel.
She really looked adorable.
So he kept booking me, booking me, booking me.
And so what's incredible
is you can have the most amazing facade
where once the mask falls down,
what's underneath can be so ugly.
So he started asking me to lose weight.
Mind you, I'm quite skinny.
I was maybe like 100 pound about.
And he told me if I get down to 80, he'll give me 20 grand.
And so slowly but surely, he grew me into being a skeleton.
And so that one time he paid me so much money, this guy.
We are talking about, like it went from like pretty woman
to like weird.
All right, so let's get to the level
of like you feeling comfortable with me now.
Let's open the creepy door.
And this is really one of the first time
I was actually introduced to the creepy.
He was into you fucking you when you are dead.
So he would pay me more and more money
as I'm playing along with the fetish.
And I never really get introduced to fetish
because I'm so organic.
And so like, let's keep it real.
So when you're asking me to just play dead
while you me fucking it's really complicated for me
to not even like moan because it feels good,
but I have to like play dead.
So slowly but surely,
I realized he had this very strange fantasy
for fucking deads, fucking dead people.
So we drifted apart, completely.
But I have to say that in the very beginning,
he made my life absolutely amazing
until he opened the door of the weirdness
which I am not down with, you know.
I wasn't down with losing 20 pounds for 20 grand.
Why?
It's weird, strange.
So as I progress in the BunnyRanch, I met this girl,
Eva Bliss, Eva Bliss, super cool, articulate, academic.
Almost like what the fuck are you doing here type of girl.
And so are you writing a book too?
And no, she was interesting.
And she told me, you know, there's like a level up to that.
I'm like, what?
She say, escorting.
Wait, not to show off or anything, but it was going on.
Escorting.
So here I am with this girl outside of the BunnyRanch,
smoking a joint, and she's telling me about escorting.
And isn't it dangerous?
She's like Frenchie, you are like this, like this,
like, so like posh and stuff.
Frenchie, you are so ignorant.
Okay, so, where do you even start?
She like do you wanna come to San Diego I show you?
Sure.
So from the bay area, I went to San Diego to see
miss Eva Bliss.
She comes to pick me up in like a bad ass carmen.
I looked at her, I was so fascinated.
Like, are you kidding me?
Blue eyes, she made on TV,
she's all over the place.
And brunettes and everything.
And she introduced me to that small little
teeny local SGASB, S-G-A-S-P,
San Diego Adult Service Provider.
Okay, oh my god.
I don't even remember how overwhelmed I felt
by the boom of demand.
It was on my phone.
Like even her, she was like in disbelief, I believe.
And so she quickly took over my account,
and I'm smart though,
so I went to that account and I would read the dynamic
of what she was doing for my booking.
And I quickly realized that she was pimping me out.
She's picking me up from the ranch.
So when she's asking me 20% versus 50%
supposed to be hallelujah, right?
And then I am at her house.
And there is this like thuggish dude that comes
with like a crystal curb.
And like, his name, like gives a shit like a pimp.
Mind you, in a bad ass luxurious gorgeous setting,
like no gorilla pimp at all,
no, like what they call like the gentleman pimp
or whatever, like is the lingo
that I don't even give a fuck of even knowing.
And I remember looking at Eva so differently,
so differently.
I could not understand this beautiful blue eye,
articulate, academic, graduated.
A plus plus plus students, unbelievable woman,
is literally leaning on a pimp.
And she's telling, Frenchie, everything I'm teaching you,
he taught me.
I'm like, yeah, cool story bro.
But if you are teaching me without him,
that means that you know it's our name.
So why do you need him?
It's more complicated than you think.
Cool, 'cause sorry sister,
but I'm not gonna stand in your circle
if it's gonna be like that.
I am absolutely not giving 20% of my pussy to a bro
that I don't even know that comes as like a gentleman pimp
with this like harmony and shit
when you are really the one bringing the money.
It did not make any fucking sense to me.
100% did not make sense to me, pause.
At the BunnyRanch when I had to give 50% to the house,
it made more sense, why?
You are giving me a safe environment
With a panic button, security, a bar,
a platform, millionaires.
Okay, sure.
It is done American style structured.
But when it's like all over the place like this,
no, because then sky's the limit to my dumbness
and how much you can manipulate this.
So I told her to fuck herself,
stay with your fucking like gentlemen pimp
that she eventually quickly fucking left.
Trust me on that one.
When she found the text that he was sending
to another girl saying like, yeah, own her.
Trust me that she fucking shaked from her toe to her head
and her head to the toe when she realized the text messages
that he was sending to a complete stranger
in order to bring her into his web.
His web of what?
You know, how he was actually laundering the money?
Carpet cleaning (laughs).
I'm a renegade.
If you are not as cool as what I can bring to myself,
please allow me to be cool with my solitude.
You're gonna have to beat my alone
in order for you to be in my life, 100%.
I mean, why is the point to have you in my life
if you not as cool as my solitude?
Doesn't make sense.
And the girl that settled down for that,
I feel bad for them because all you have to do
is just this little awakening.
You don't need someone that brings you down.
It's your Clyde to your Bonnie
and your Bonnie to your Clyde or nothing.
It cannot be somebody that makes money out of your pussy
without even bringing anything to the plate.
Baby girl, you built the table.
And you are the one building the place.
He did not even bring the fork, yet alone the spoon
or the glass.
So why would you give everything to a guy
that really gonna manage your money, it's a lifestyle.
I am so confused when I hear those lingo,
because if everything is lingo at the end of the story,
and I'm not better or worst or superior
or inferior than anyone,
but I made the choice to be a renegade,
independent, beautiful, strong little woman,
five to 100 pounds alone.
Absolutely alone, I had so many pimps
approaching me from left to right.
And I tell him, baby boy, you think I need you?
You need me?
Let me show you the game.
There is this big black guy one day, came,
yeah, and so it's funny because I do ask the call
in order to pick up on the voices in the frequency.
He was with this motherfucker
because not only I could not pick up on like the thuggy,
the trick, like the pimp shit.
No, he came came on my door, like pimp like gorilla,
okay, all right, let's do this.
So I remember it's two way it's gonna go.
Like, bad or real bad or good or real good.
So he smelled my weed.
He went around, yeah.
I'm like, can you please sit down?
And I had my joint...my spliff, and I passed it on to him.
And so in order to maybe communicate with someone,
you have to maybe go into the maybe like street
or book smart, street smart.
Street smart, all right, let's go street smart.
No problem.
So I told him, big daddy, I am 38 years old.
I remember the body language.
Okay, she's definitely older than me.
I'm older than most of my clients.
And I tell him, okay, so you come,
not only you wasting in my time,
I got ready for you above the hour.
His voice was deep voice,
almost like an older white dude.
Like kind of like, I don't know.
I could not pick up on the thuggy street, nothing.
That's why I got like double scared, like shit,
he got his game, really good.
Like wow, because like the lack of girls,
I'm looking for all the girls,
I'm like, okay, baby, boy,
first of all I don't need you,
yet you need me.
Here, I'm going to text you a link to this platform,
this platform, this platform.
Oh my goodness, my goodness.
You're gonna find so many girls that's gonna need you.
Me?
The only motherfucker I give my money to was Dennis Hof,
and Dennis Hof only, why?
Because you had a way to bring the fucking millionaires
to the BunnyRanch to do...
Thank you, and he gave me a big papa hug,
and he even texted me, thank you.
And I sent him the link, just like I told him.
Find the girls that need you.
There is niche and categories, okay?
I am a professor at this point.
I can teach you.
You're not gonna teach me.
What are you gonna teach me?
Life taught me so many things.
It's not the years that you have into your lives,
it's how many lives you have into your years,
really, you know.
And I have many, oh my god.
I was taught by the best with the best,
Air Force Amy, crazy motherfucker Air Force Amy,
Jazzy Jazz, like 20 old, like that, just get it together.
She was so articulate.
Kenny Parker, amazing fucking names.
I was around them, you know...young.
So I kind of know my shit at this point,
and they taught me, you need to make a brand name.
So construct your brand name.
And over the years, I construct my brand name.
But back to San Diego, we see Fabulous.
Yeah, when I partied aside with her in San Diego,
I realized it was a huge market for little spinner
little girls, European, escorting.
And then they use different niche and level.
And then suddenly like, again, life and universe
throw lemons, and you make lemon drop with sugar rims,
and you get best out of life.
And my remedy was no to use your drugs, 100%.
Drugs at the end of your life, 70-75,
shoot everything, fucking go into La Land if you need to.
Be sober for you anyway.
But 20, 25, 30, 19, 18, 16.
Why?
Is so early.
You fuck shit up so much
with using the shit that is so insignificant right now.
It will fuck you up no matter what.
You already saw the vision of him and him and him.
How you going to think for a second
that you are going to be the one
that should say Ray is going to be successful.
Ray Charles?
Are you Ray Charles?
There is one Ray Charles.
It's not everybody who can be a functional addict.
You know, and it's not drug at all
that is going to make your life easier.
It's going to make your life fucking hell.
So the secret of success is when life
throw lemons at you, make a lemon drop,
don't make a fucking fix, not yet,
65, 70 years old.
Oh my god, go to La Land.
I will go to La Land, trust me, 100%.
I am going to be the most fucked up grandma
that you ever seen because I have nothing to lose yet.
But when you're 20, you have so much to leave.
So much to know, is too early.
It's not the time.
Everything is balanced.
And at your early ages and the beginning of your life,
it is not the time to intoxicate yourself.
Be stuck with shit that will bring you
no matter what in the wrong path, no matter what.
Is zero chance, you're gonna be successful,
fucking cocaine, methyl.
Do you see many of them?
Ray Charles motherfucker, Ray Charles.
Are you Ray Charles?
And if you aren't, don't fucking think that.
Because you did it, you can, no.
He was blind.
That's why you had to fill up a void.
What void do you have to fill up at 20 year?
Success, ambition, that's what you need
to fill up yourself with.
Get high up on that.
But getting high on substances that you already knew
was gonna fuck yourself up,
it's such a dumb move, it really is.
Weed, it's already a poison.
Tobacco is a poison.
My little vodka peach red bull is a poison
but this is how are we modulate enough to enhance my mood.
And sometime maybe fill up my void.
But you don't have to go so deep, so deep, so deep.
It's not even necessary.
Sometime really giving a high five to a stranger
can feel you a better than a fix,
but you don't realize it because you don't try.
So try it, it's cool, you know.
- [Mark] So what have you learned about men
from doing this?
You've been doing it for how long now?
- 12.
- [Mark] 12 years, you've been doing this.
What have you learned about men?
- The good, the bad and the ugly.
I learned that men are just creatures.
I asked sometime my clients,
especially the handsome ones,
open my door and I have clark Kent,
beautiful little puppy.
And I ask him, what is it, why?
So I have different answers.
You know, sometimes it's like the lack of the scene
or my wife and I, it's a little bit complicated
or my wife is wonderful but I like the peach
and the banana and the melon.
And then you slowly realize that sometime
they don't even have a problem.
They just need to fulfill something that men's needs
which is variety, which is so complicated to understand
as a woman because we just really need one we can lean on.
And we so romantic in a hopeless ways
that you think is gonna be eternal.
And one is going to be like the Prince charming,
like the Hollywood movie and stuff.
So we believe in that so much.
And the guys are so detached,
and it's this clash of emotion, expectation.
And you quickly realize that it's just the illusion.
But when you're the mistress, it's not normal.
You're back to reality to where you understand the illusion
of being a wife and like this hopeless, romantic,
gorgeous princess is getting lied to by prince charming
to go with the mistress.
And I was the wife at one point of my life.
And then I became the princess, the mistress
where you'd never lie to the mistress.
You don't need to.
You lie to the wife
to be with the mistress.
You don't fight with the mistress,
you fight with the wife in order to be with the mistress.
So as life throws you lemons again, what do you do?
You do a lemon drop with a little bit of Chambord raspberry
with sugar and then you understand
that man will need the sugar where they even have it at home
but they don't realize it no more.
So they try to get the sugar with you
and her and her and her,
and it's fucked up fucking relationship
that they built with their wife.
But again, I'd rather be on the mistress side
than the wife side because I was at one point in my life.
And it wasn't fun.
- [Mark] Do you believe in love?
- Yes, yes, yes.
I believe in love.
And I think there is so many levels into relationships,
like soulmates, compatibility, sugar baby, sugar daddy,
let's belong together.
Let's be fucked up together.
Like there is so many,
and everybody really wants to find their soulmates
but you only know it's your soulmate
after 15, 20 years where you went through the good,
the hard, the good, like punches of life
and you stay so strong together
that it actually gets you stronger,
or the hate, like you know those couple
they want to make you vomit because they're so cute.
You know, they're so cute.
Like how are you so cute?
And they feed off of that.
They feed off of your vomit, and this is soulmates.
And a lot of people wanna be that
but only a few are going to be it.
It's a lot of compatibility.
And compatibility, we go down to sheet five,
seven years, each nine years, 10 years, the kids.
And then I call an escort, five, six, 700, $900 an hour.
And I will lie to you, my special wife,
to be with a perfect stranger.
And not knock on the door, and you open in your lingerie,
and he is beautiful.
And he has nothing wrong at home.
He has a wonderful wife
but he wants to pitch
because you had the apple for too long.
- [Mark] A lot of your clients are married,
I take it.
- All of them.
- [Mark] All of them (laughs).
- Most of them.
Like is a lot of very young because there is no scene.
- [Mark] A lot of the what?
- Very young.
- [Mark] Oh, very young.
- Young because the scene, the club and the strip club
and party, festival, lots of things are closed.
So a lot of people that used
to put their selection to the test
and sometime have effortlessly bitches
throwing themselves at them, it stopped.
And so it's cute to actually see like,
oh, maybe this score is going to give me
her attention and love.
Then they pay one time and they try
to do the off the plug thing,
which is kind of like endearing.
Like, oh, are you as cool as my job
or cooler than the job that I'm gonna quit for you?
No, I'm not going to quit my job for any guy.
No, actually I think that is the guy
that would not ask me to quit the job
that I would quit the job for.
Yeah, for sure.
I have millionaires throwing themselves at me at this point.
I ask them one particular, why?
Close to Einstein engineers type of...
I love nerds, I don't know.
Something about nerds, that is super nerd.
And then he's like, you are my 1%.
It's cute.
You know, I am his 1%, me, as an escort.
And he thrives so much of my energy,
who I am, how I do things.
And it's until that I told him what fucks us up
is that you are a millionaire.
And from the start, he is fucked.
I am not going to move into your castle.
I wanna put my brick, put your brick.
And then we construct our empire.
If I would be next to you as you broke,
and then you become a millionaire, I am next to you.
So it doesn't mean that I was interested
but now like the chance of me slightly being interested
always will cross your mind.
And I don't want to always work on eggshell
to make you feel like you not just the wallet.
He does give me orgasm every single time we had sex.
It's wonderful, it's next level orgasm.
And so I had to ask myself, okay, if you removed the castle,
the infinity pool, the fortune,
but it's not that that makes my pussy wet
or my orgasms.
You know, it is not.
So I had to realize, yeah, I am in love with him.
And I have beautiful sex with him.
But because he's a millionaire,
he is fucking shit up, I can't.
And a lot of girls would tell me, are you crazy?
Yeah, I am not interested, no.
So I tell him because he helps me a lot with my Bitcoin
and everything, so he tell me,
you see we're gonna be millionaire together.
Like he is so next level, like how you reach that.
We so fucked from the start, you know what I mean?
So I tell him like, maybe let's just go broke together,
and go to Costa Rica and build a hat.
He's like, yes.
Then he's telling me how we going to construct a hat
with an elevator.
And it's so smart, it's so cool.
It's so, I don't know.
It's almost like I need to flip a coin with him.
I don't know.
Like, I'm in love but I'm scared.
I don't wanna be with the rich guy
that always going to fucking think
like maybe she's with me for my money, which I'm not.
- [Mark] Are you making money?
- Lot, yeah, he knows--
- [Mark] You must be saving money, right?
- Yeah, I was a banker.
Yeah, money is at this point once again,
it's part of the equation, obviously,
who does everything for free?
- [Mark] And you're happy too, you're happy?
- Fuck, yeah.
Oh yeah, no, yeah, I'm happy.
You know those little like grandma that can like look back
and high-five themselves on their death bed, you know?
Yeah, oh yeah, for sure.
No regrets, I don't...
Life is so absurd that do what the you wanna do
but don't hurt no one in the process, not even yourself.
Your choices will sculpt your destiny.
It's a game of choices.
You can be an amazing student, but it's the school of life.
And it will, like a dodge ball like if you need to dodge
dangers, temptations, drugs will be tsunami.
Men, men will be your tsunami,
men will be tsunami, and your best friend as well.
You need to know who's who.
Use your intuition.
As women, we have the feminine intuition.
I mean, it's clearly undeniable, it's there.
If you have a voice within tell you is wrong, it is wrong.
If it's too good to be true,
it is too good to be true, most likely.
Listen to the little voice within.
It's important to have it and to understand is there,
is there for a reason, you know?
I mean, we gifted with that.
So I'm happy.
I'm a happy person in a fucked up world.
So one step at a time, I can change it,
but can I a change the whole thing?
I wish but I am not that strong.
I had big shoes to fill,
and I'm just a fucking 35, 5.5 in America, little, little.
- [Mark] Do you see yourself settling down
and having kids one day?
- No.
- [Mark] No?
- [Mark] Not your thing.
- No, no kids, isn't my story.
I'd rather have a cat or dog at this point.
It's not against the kids, but it's the generation of tech,
digital, swiping left, vital reality.
Do I want to have a kid just like with a mask
on his face and...
No, nope, I think I pass.
- [Mark] What would you say
is the most important lesson you've learned in your life?
- But again, I seen the universe manifesting
in mysterious ways.
And if there is like a train
that goes into a certain direction
and the destination says, paradise,
don't fucking miss the train.
Like are you fucking serious
because it might be that one chance.
You can jump on it.
So choices will sculp your destiny, 100%.
One choice is like the butterfly effect,
this, this, this, this.
Oh my god, the movie "Run Lola Run."
What a movie, "Run Lola Run."
Once again, can change the whole course of your life.
And a cigarette changed the course of my life.
Working in a bank, changed the whole course of my life.
Working at the BunnyRanch changed the course of my life.
Like it's a beautiful, entrepreneur slash
I wanna fuck a skeleton.
So my life, it's so absurd.
So again, like lemons are opportunity.
Catch them, jiggle and make a lemon drop.
I love lemon drops.
- [Mark] Thank you, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Mark, I'm so happy
you are so patient with me like that.
- [Mark] It's like a movie.
- (giggles) (indistinct)
- [Mark] Thank you.
(Frenchie laughs)
Oh my god, that was so fun.
- A lot.
- [Mark] That was so fun.
(background noise drains other sounds)